what we've done is I've got a radiation
source which is emitting a constant
stream of electrons as there's neutrons
that are keying into protons out pops an
electron and I'm counting how many of
those not how many it's giving out but
how many of them are going into the
Geiger counter that's a slightly
different number okay well yes so it's
about 20 per second going into the
Geiger counter and then I'm feeding that
into this little box which is just
turning that number into a voltage so
these two wires are collecting that
voltage and they're passing them into
the oscilloscope where we can see the
pulses as they go by each pulse
represents one electron and electrons
are all the same so those pulses are all
the same height right and so as those
pulses flash by I'm counting them the
computer is counting them so the wire
comes out of the oscilloscope it goes
through this little breakout box and
into the back of the computer you can
buy one of these things for about 200
quid by the way they're worth having
right into the back of the computer and
then I've written a little computer
program and all the computer program
does is sit there for 10 seconds and
countesses that's it it's really simple
it's all graphs today right here's time
along here and the stream of electrons
look something like this
as they're coming out and they're
randomly distributed which my stream of
electrons absolutely isn't right and I'm
all I'm doing is I'm counting so I start
with a value of zero and then I get to
this time and I'm adding 1 I get here 2
3 4 5 6 8 9 and so on right and this is
where the probability bit comes in
because the chances are that over 10
seconds remember this rough so so the
most likely number that we're going to
get here and measured this this morning
is 216 over 10 seconds over 10 seconds
right okay and that's just an empirical
measurement so I'm taking the number
that I've counted up and I'm going to
subtract off 216 what we've just seen
then whether the answer was 13 then
obviously either I've come in here and
I'm gonna get this right I've had 229 or
it could equally be that I've been here
and had 203 both of those are going to
give the answer of 13 so the reason
that's happened is I did I wasn't
interested in showing you a negative
random number I wanted to show you an
integer value a positive integer family
yeah so so I just wrote a piece of
software where I squared it up I took
the square root the square roots never
to be positive and so my software is
always going to give a positive answer I
cheated all right okay I admit it I
cheated but the answer is 13 so you want
some more numbers right okay well I'll
generate a few more we don't know yet so
well we should we start with the 0 and
the 13
right or do you want to just start with
the 13 so we have had 0 we've had 13 now
we have 27 5 5 this is like they really
should use radiation sources for the
lottery nobody would be cheating for
sure it doesn't quite have the
razzamatazz of the lottery 44 last seen
three weeks ago today but hang on a
second this would be a bad way to do the
lottery because some numbers here are
more likely than other ones right so
that's a really good point that you've
made the some maths which I left out of
this video because because I thought it
was going too far where you can turn a
Gaussian distribution into a uniform
distribution
so you can take your Gaussian
distribution of random numbers and you
can flip it around and give them all a
uniform probability okay now I don't
want to do the maths for you because
that would be painful for everybody but
it works and so you can then generate a
uniform probability sequence of numbers
that's absolutely not what we've done
though what we've done is we've taken a
Gaussian distribution and so some
numbers 0 basically are going to be more
likely than others I'm really quite
enjoying this it's very satisfying 3 ok
I'll run another one and we'll count up
so the computer again is counting 200
ish electrons and this is the deviation
6 is the deviation from the mean and
because it's got a Gaussian distribution
the smaller numbers are more probable so
if we keep doing this what we're going
to end up with is very heavily weighted
to the small numbers right it's actually
quite surprising to me that we haven't
seen 0 again yet I should say this
morning 9 excellent this morning's
before you arrived I ran thousands of
these just to check that it was Gaussian
not the nature was suddenly going to do
something different so the computer is
counting the number of electrons that
strontium is putting out and in this
case it's either put out 20 more than
the average number of electrons or it's
put out 20 less I can't tell because
I've I've hidden that in my code but
it's 20 away from the average so in the
science of Statistics this is 10
excellent in the science of Statistics
yeah sorry on your head beer George
thank you 19 so that's 19 more or less
electrons than the average value that
the strontium is putting out so in this
case it's been quite an active 10
seconds for the strontium okay that's
surprising hey ray so this is this the
truth of it it could well be that I got
the mean in the wrong place so that
really explained and eventually that
would show up so there's one last thing
I'd like to show you and that is
essentially well let me just show you
and then I can talk about it right
I'm going to run the experiment 1000
times over and we made that nice and big
so each one of these pulses that you can
see appearing that's one number that
we've generated okay and as you can see
we're generating more and more numbers
and each time I'm adding one to this
pulse and so the most likely number at
the moment is 20 this tells us that I
got the main wrong okay
so if if I've got the mean right then
this value would be zero okay what this
means is that I got the mean wrong by
probably by 20 which is the mean being
one okay I what this means is that I've
gotten the mean number of electrons that
this thing's giving out in ten seconds I
got that completely wrong which is a bit
embarrassing but but you can see now
that it's starting to take this this
Gaussian form so it started off just as
a couple of posters and you'd never have
known that there was a Gaussian
distribution to that but over time it
grows into a really nice bell-shaped
graph and we can see that the most
likely number that we're going to
generate has moved up a bit from 20 now
it's about 22
that also means when we ran the
experiment earlier and we got a zero as
our first result that was actually quite
an unlikely result yeah absolutely so
that would mean that that effectively
zero was more like a twenty result and
all of the 20s and 19's that we got in
the 27 that we got before these were
much more likely so it wasn't it wasn't
perfect that but it was alright I think
and I think that we got a nice a nice
random number from it so I'm pretty
pleased
so that was still random this doesn't
affect the randomness of the numbers no
no again this goes back to the semantics
of it right this is is it it's random
yes but it has a particular probability
associated with choosing that number so
at the moment the probability of
choosing something less than about eight
is zero and the probability of choosing
something more than 38 is zero if we go
for a very very long time an infinitely
long time then these numbers will become
nonzero but they're going to be very
close to zero when you live them an
outlier they're now near 40 don't we
yeah it's quite satisfying just watching
this graph drawer itself every time
question is how much time do you have